ja und hier im studio begrüße ich
professor stephan fröhlich
politikwissenschaftler von der
universität
erlangen-nürnberg ich fange mal und mit
dem an was zumindest mich heute am
meisten beunruhigt hat das war dieser
vorgang dass putin da seine
atomstreitkräfte in alarmbereitschaft
versetzt hat wie ordnen sie das seien
also zunächst mal glaube ich dass das
nicht nur sie heute am meisten ärgert
sondern ich glaube das hat alle die
ganze welt am meisten beunruhigt dass er
diese karte tatsächlich jetzt in diesem
augenblick zu diesem moment zieht und
damit droht man eigentlich bleibt nichts
anderes mehr darüber hinaus gibt es
nichts das ist das schlimmste was
passieren kann
erstaunt uns einmal mehr hat uns ohnehin
in den letzten wochen denke ich
überrascht und das ganze hat eine
eigendynamik entwickelt die wir denke
ich aber auch an alle nicht vermutet
hätten den kühnsten träumen und sich
nicht hätten vorstellen können dass
diese drohung kommt und da hilft auch
nichts dass wir immer wieder darauf
hingewiesen haben dass russland in den
letzten jahren kontinuierlich den
letzten zehn jahren systematisch seine
nuklearen waffenarsenale modernisiert
hat wo man dann auch fragt für was
abschreckung ja also insofern ist das
mehr als beunruhigend und wie man es
deuten soll ist ist in ist sehr schwer
es ist wirklich sehr schwer es hat so
ein bisschen den eindruck als hätte er
sich tatsächlich ein bisschen in eine
sackgasse manövriert dass er das selbst
auch überrollt wird über durch durch die
ereignisse von den ereignissen und das
heißt natürlich insbesondere widerstand
der ukraine und widerstand kehrt das
sich nicht so ohne weiteres eben zu
friedensverhandlungen bereit erklärt hat
beziehungsweise zur aufgabe und
natürlich auch die solidarität im westen
wobei ich nicht glaube dass er diese
dass er diesmal ähnlich wie 2014 nicht
ahnen musste oder nicht geahnt hat dass
er diesmal mit einer massiven und front
ist zu tun bekommt deswegen wird das so
ein bisschen fast wie eine
verzweiflungstat zu einem zeitpunkt
schon wo er tatsächlich in einer
sackgasse steckt und
man kann nur hoffen wirklich nur hoffen
dass das eben wir haben das ja eben auch
dass das den druck
erheblich erhöht auch im innern in
moskau in russland also das bleibt zur
hoffnung ich bin auch der meinung dass
wir nicht davon abweichen sollten und er
kann auch nicht in einem entfernten
glauben dass der letzten jetzt
zurückziehen sagt also wir werden unsere
sanktionen uns noch einmal überlegen
darüber denken wir zieht es zurück nicht
denkbar